history being made on capitol hill and
the front pages from newspapers all
around the country really tell the story
here
judge katanji brown jackson is
officially confirmed as the first black
woman ever to serve on the supreme court
every democrat and three republican
senators voted for her and she watched
the vote with president biden nicole
killian is at the supreme court with
more on this story nicole i think a lot
of people around the country watch this
vote i have to say it was pretty
exciting to see good morning to you hey
good morning to you gail and very
emotional and when judge katanji brown
jackson becomes justice jackson for the
first time in the supreme court's
history she will be one of two african
americans on the high court one of four
women and the first public defender
on this vote the a's are 53
the nays are 47
and this nomination is confirmed it was
a moment of historic celebration
shears erupted from the senate floor
to watch parties across the country and
the white house where president biden
embraced judge katanji brown jackson as
she became the first black woman to be
confirmed to the supreme court snapping
a selfie he tweeted we've taken another
step toward making our highest court
reflect the diversity of america after
presiding over the vote vice president
kamala harris a first in her own right
said she was deeply moved i do believe
is a very important statement about who
we are as a nation the 51 year old
mother of two stood firm on her career
accomplishments during the senate
hearings the harvard law grad clerked
under justice breyer and serves on the
d.c appeals court the judge also has
nine years of experience on the federal
bench three republicans joined democrats
to back her nomination no senator i
didn't say verse that's exactly what you
said despite some who tried to depict
jackson as soft on crime and a judicial
activist i believe she will prove to be
the furthest left
of any justice to have ever served on
the supreme court one of the reasons why
i spoke out so firmly is because i know
the disrespect that african-american
women have faced new jersey's cory
booker defended jackson during the
hearings and is one of only three
african-americans in the senate what did
this vote mean to you personally i mean
it's a jackie robinson moment that we're
witnessing here this
class ceiling being shattered in a way
that's going to have profound
implications for our country
judge jackson will appear with president
biden and vice president harris later
today at the white house she will
replace retiring justice stephen breyer
but she's not expected to be sworn in
until after he steps down at the end of
the supreme court's term this summer
gail
boy nicole i can't imagine how she must
be feeling today she woke up knowing
that she made history and in a very good
way i so look forward to i hope to meet
her one day have you ever met her and
you're trying i haven't met her but i
certainly followed her around the hill
quite a bit to the point where she and
her team probably got tired of me but
she was always very gracious and a few
times she did say hello
yes it's a very proud moment for a lot
of people today thank you nicole killian